[Music]
many of you wondered how the footage
looks like straight out of the camera so
this is a short comparison between the
profiles and a brief introduction to the
creative bloods
[Music]
[Applause]
let's start with the comparison
[Music]
this was shot at correct temperature and
exposure without any color filter but
normally i wouldn't use them like so
actually this is not how i use them at
all because some profiles look better
underexposed and some profiles
overexpose they're all different if
needed i'll make a video explain how i
normally shoot each profile in terms of
exposure temperature and color filter
but at the moment i only had this much
time to make a short video in which i
answered some of the most asked
questions
one of the most important factors in
good prediction of the profiles is the
use of the color
i always shift towards cyan green
magenta or yellow to give a different
hue variation depending on each
individual profile
i also recorded a color checker so you
can easily see the differences in color
between each profile
many of you asked about luts at the
moment i'm working on multiple creative
luts so you have more options to choose
from when grading footage i'll come back
with a new video showing how to use the
creative blots and explain how to use
luts in a more efficient way subscribe
if you want to see that video coming
till then i'll leave you with a sunday
morning video featuring the blue velvet
film profile
this footage is basically straight out
of the camera only with some
unsharpening and film noise added which
is base [ __ ]
the more i use this profile the more i
love it because of its deep velvety
blues and the nostalgic feeling that it
has to it
so guys this is it happy holidays
subscribe like or buy me a coffee if you
appreciate the content and don't forget
to have fun with these profiles
and let us know if you like them or if
you don't that's fine leave a comment
and see you later
[Music]
you